welcome back to scrambled except this  time is done with a difference because  we  are in west sumatra an amazing safari  park tasmania  norway india in the middle of the jungle  right on the edge of this  almighty amazon it'll be a traditional  scrambled egg but done with a little bit  of black masala  [ __ ] the local duck eggs look at the  color of those goats  it's an ostrich egg and base those eggs  turn the heat up unscrambled now don't  get upset  i thought i'd do a reindeer omelette hey  kid look she's looking at you  these are literally hand-dived  [Music]  oh my god how beautiful  breakfast sandwich  omelette hot spicy and delicious